now i would like to introduce y'all to
the man the myth the legend
the mvp front runner if anybody else got
to say something different about that
then come see me y'all i'm right here be
more outside the bank if you got an
issue with that come see me
about that
big trust
one of the great moments of the 2017
season or any season it was magical
what is that though what is the signal
it's just it's just the universal trust
signal that's the universal universal
trust signal we just kind of came up
with it you did okay yeah when did it
start
man lamar man he just been saying trust
like you know
it's like kind of i'm with you you know
what i mean and uh i just put the kind
of the big on it because we do
everything big so he'd be like trust
trust i'd be like big trust you know
what i mean and um i said it in the
interview messing around
me lamar met junon we was all right
there messing around and um
it went viral so it's crazy oh it's
awesome mark ingram with us here ravens
running back and it was a strange year
for you all those seasons with the
saints you jump into a new team the
great unknown you don't know what it's
going to be you end up on one of the
best teams in the nfl yeah man um like
you said
in free agency you know
believing the ravens wanted me and uh
you know i wanted to be there and um you
know it ended up being a perfect match
they accepted me they allowed me to be
myself the organization's first class
from top to bottom the guys in the
locker room accepted me and embraced me
with open arms and um i think we were
just able to thrive together as a unit
had a great group of guys a great
organization who was on one court and um
we're looking to you know pick up right
where we left off next year like i mean
you guys took the league by storm but
like tell me best way to describe
playing with lamar jackson man it's just
he's just a special guy man just uh
obviously the athletic ability able to
throw the ball able to run the ball the
leadership but uh i think just the
person he is it just makes people
gravitate towards him uh the person he
is the the type of person he is it makes
you want to be the be at your best
because you don't want to let him down
you want to make you want to be at your
best so you can make his job as easy as
possible and i think um everybody in our
whole entire organization rallied behind
them support them we want to be the best
we can so we can help them be successful
and ultimately win a championship
and the season was so great the regular
season but and you know look
the thing about the playoffs you never
know what's gonna happen exactly when
you look back on that you rewind that
and i'm sure you've been thinking about
like what what what could have gone
differently what will go differently the
next time how do you carry from what
happened against tennessee so next time
you guys punch them and you're here yeah
i think you have to
know that there's always in the game
three to four to five plays that
essentially you know
determine the game and you never know
when those players are going to be so
you have to be physically execute
physically mentally emotionally you have
to be on point you have to be executing
every single play because you never know
when those players are going to arise
you know we had a couple a turnover here
uh didn't get a couple fourth downs
there that we didn't capitalize the
tennessee capitalized on it and you know
that kind of makes the game go upside
down now you're playing the game that
you're you know behind doing some things
you don't want to do then essentially
you run out of time so um you just have
to have that focus um that toughness
that ability to execute in high pressure
situations so
you don't have the mistakes but you're
capitalizing on other team's mistakes
there
been in that situation so i i am like do
you think that affected you guys no i
don't think it affected us right um
i think you know you could point out a
couple plays like i said we had we're
driving the ball our defense gets you
three and out we're driving the ball if
mark andrews doesn't have a high ankle
sprain maybe he can jump about here
right and they don't get the
interception that goes and then they
score a touchdown right and you know
maybe if we get our fourth down they
don't take our defense up top the next
playing score 14-0 we fight back to 14-6
we're driving the ball yeah and we don't
get another point right and then three
plays later derrick breaks the big run
now you're down 21-6 that quick yeah
with a couple mistakes right i mean so
right i think it's just that important
to be on point and not have those
mistakes because essentially they hurt
you especially if you make them and the
other team capitalizes on them like
tennessee did in that game yeah is it
tough being here when you like look up
and see 49ers and chiefs and you think
we're better than both these teams man
yeah it does hurt and we do feel like
we're the best team in the nfl but
in our league you have one game
elimination so if you're not at your
best when you have one game elimination
you get sent home and as simple as that
so
we're sitting here we're going to watch
the super bowl we're going to watch
somebody hold up this lombardi trophy
and that's going to hurt that's going to
sting but we got to use that as fuel and
motivation to get back in the lab stay
grinding and be better next year give us
the the you played both of them give us
the scouting report on the team like
what jumps out to you about the chiefs
and the niners listen the chiefs you
have a high-powered offense an elite
quarterback who creates things when
there's nothing there you have these
speedy receivers that can run routes
catch the ball it's be explosive you
have good backs damien williams lesean
mccoy so you have a high powered offense
against their defense who front four is
tremendous they eat the linebackers
the the secondary they all play well as
a unit um they're physical they get
after it then you have the 49ers offense
smash mouth hard nose run it at you play
action you will kittle play action you
give debo samuel all kinds of sweeps
they got emmanuel sanders so they have
elite weapons passion ball although
they've been running it they only put
eight times last week and then you have
the chiefs defense which they've been
playing a lot better as of lately they
have and um you know so i think it's
gonna be a close game i think it's gonna
be a great game but um you know i think
pat mahomes is going to kind of do his
thing and he's going to overcome it yeah
i i don't know he's just been kind of
doing it i know he's kind of doing it
somehow so but like i said the 49ers
have a strong defense so i'm looking
forward to see what's going to happen
that's the best defense you played this
year you think the 49ers it was a weird
game because you were in a wet run in
the rain yeah it kind of rained but it
was a physical tough game it was and you
could feel it like this definitely could
be a rematch in the super bowl right
yeah we felt that yeah but um so i i
hey the knight is tough man so we'll see
we'll see we'll see i think it's gonna
be a real good game we got a game we've
been playing with our guests because we
talk a lot all year long we say a lot of
things some things we regret but some
things we stand by yeah you got to guess
who said this chris or me
mark ingram is better now than he was
with the saints he's a bully he plows
into the line and you can't stop him who
said that trump said that who said it i
don't even know who said i think you
said that oh i said it my guy here we go
my guy
hey i appreciate you
it was amazing though because look
running backs we know what happens right
you get beat up you get broken down
you're not supposed to be running the
way you're running at the age of 30. you
turned 30 back in november i think it
was december yeah and it was amazing to
me to see how you it was just no
hesitation off and and you just would
pound and pound and just physically
overpower that's why i look at the 49ers
and see how they run the ball i mean
that's kind of the way you were running
the ball all year long and you just
break the physical will of the of the
defense and they they basically give up
yeah when you control the ball and your
offensive line is dominant and hitting
people in the mouth like if even if
you're not having success with the wrong
game or early it's like body shots in a
boxing match like you're just wearing on
them just wearing on them just wearing
on them you know even if it's two yards
you're just wearing on them then you hit
eight yards and you're just wearing on
them and then you just three out three
yards you're just wearing on them and
then in the fourth quarter
you know
they the big ones come you know
you start hitting 15 yards
yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're getting a little more tired
they're getting a little bit more they
don't want to take on those pulling
guards right same so right the the the
running game is such a
asset to a team
it helps your defense stay off the field
it helps your quarterback get
comfortable he he gets play action you
know what i mean so it just keeps the
defense off balance it keeps your team
in in control of the game so a run game
is a huge asset to a team guys get that
look too you we can see it watching on
tv you surely sense it when you're on
the field i call it the i just want to
go home right i just get that i
i want to go home and i want to crawl
into bed and be done with this all right
we got another game we've been playing a
little face swap we take a couple of
guys from your team maybe a coach maybe
a player slam them together and you have
to tell us who they are i think we got a
few that we're going to roll what do we
have first who's that oh my gosh man i
know one i just thought that tucker
harbaugh there you go i got it
boom
okay yeah let's move on that was good
that was well done
number two brandon carr and
ah
you got half of it right and hollywood i
don't know it is that's it he's two for
two last one here we go last one this is
the tough one
me
and lj
hey give us the gatorade pitch hey man
you know man y'all we've been drinking
gatorade you always do that during your
activity but now we got the off the
field hydration drink boat 24. they got
everything you need the antioxidants the
electrolytes the vitamins i got the
watermelon strawberry right here one of
my personal favorites right but this is
your you know off the field drink stay
hydrated so you can perform at a high
level at an optimal level we got bamboo
running back reunion here hey d roll
tide
about to get that money yeah yeah both
24 he'd be on it too
both 24. gatorade sorry let me check
that out check that out man i will
yeah it looks it's i can't know
artificial flavors we got the
watermelon all about the all-natural i'm
all about it we in there hey you're some
leader too man you're a player i don't
know what it is you better team you go
to it seems like they like you so
there's something to be said about that
i appreciate it it was fun to watch and
we're looking forward we're ravens fans
in 2020 big trust woo woo offense
yes sir
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports